what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really big DC
news not only are we going to be talking
about the upcoming slate including when
that is going to actually be revealed by
James Gunn and Peter Safran but it is
now confirmed that the DCU the DC
Universe is now going to be completely
rebooted they are resetting the DCU they
are not soft rebooting it but completely
rebooting it and this is coming from
Dave Batista who said he spoke with
James Gunn and that is what James Gunn
told him it's actually very interesting
how he got into this conversation with
James Gunn he spoke to him about
possibly playing Bane now of course many
people know that Dave Bautista and James
Gunn have worked a lot with each other
of course Dave Batista plays Drax and
Guardians of the Galaxy in which of
course the franchise is written by and
directed by James Gunn and what's really
interesting is that James Gunn recently
said on Twitter that he will probably
work with this cast again at DC in fact
he said he knows he's going to work with
them again and then he said probably at
his new gig which of course is him
running DC Studios luckily for us Dave
Bautista has revealed the conversation
that he had with James Gunn about
playing Bane or I should say not playing
Bane and about the reboot of the DCU
Dave Batista said I have had
conversations with James about that but
I think the direction he's leaning in
completely rebooting that whole universe
he's starting from scratch and starting
younger and fresher and I think you need
to do that this was with an interview
with Insider that Dave Bautista was
doing for his movie knock at the cabin
and he continued to say I thank for the
DC Universe to be revived you need to
start from scratch I think you need to
start with younger actors you need to
start to plan for the next 15 years and
I just don't think you can do that with
me and I understand that and also I have
to say that I appreciate that because I
don't want to play a character that I
can't bring Justice to I don't think at
this point in my career that I can bring
Justice to Bane anymore I just don't
know if I could handle the physical part
and I don't think I would have the
longevity to plan ahead for films so I
just don't know if I'd be that guy and
the title for this article from Insider
is Dave Batista says he's talked to
James Gunn about playing Bane and it's
not happening he's starting from scratch
and right away go ahead and let us know
what you think about this in the
comments down below we'd love to hear
what you think but I personally think
that this is truly the way to go at this
point in time DC has been very confusing
if you've been a fan of the DC franchise
you definitely know this the DC EU
really lacked connectivity and
continuity plus you have things like the
Snyder cut and then you have a whole
entire Another Universe with the joker
and then the Batman Universe and it's
very convoluted and it makes it really
hard to see what DC's overall plan is so
it's great that James Gunn and Peter
saffron are coming in with a plan to
reboot the entire thing yes some of
these actors will be missed for sure and
it is a kick in the shin since we just
got Henry Cavill back a Superman in
Black Adam that was going to be awesome
but James Gunn has met with Henry Cavill
already and has told him that they are
going a different direction which is
what Dave Batista is saying they are
rebooting and casting younger actors to
play the roles and it's just like Dave
Batista said they need actors that can
last the next 15 years think about the
start of the MCU with Iron Man how he
lasted all the way to Avengers endgame
and think about Thor he is still
currently in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right now he's lasted over 10
years this is something that the DCU
needs we need actors who are going to be
around for a very long time so we can
have that continuity and that
connectivity so I think this is an
incredibly good idea however I do want
to address the fact that some actors
like Jason Momoa and Zachary Levi said
that they aren't really going anywhere
Jason Momoa was recently talking about
Aquaman 3 and he basically told us that
he is playing Lobo in the new DCU so
that was really confusing fans thought
well is he going to play Aquaman and
Lobo then Zachary Levi was tweeting at
people stating to not really worry about
his future with the DC Universe and that
he's really not going anywhere but I
think these actors are kind of being
intentionally misleading and not really
for a bad reason but let me explain if
you have a movie coming up that is set
in a universe that is about to expire
like Shazam 2 and Aquaman 2. the hype
for it might kind of get diminished a
little bit in fact I've already seen
tons of tweets about this with people
stating well if the universe is about to
get reset and these actors aren't going
to play these characters anymore why
even go see the movie now I get people
saying that but I don't share that
mentality I think both movies are going
to be very enjoyable and I'm gonna go
see both and I do think that Zachary
Levi is going to be done as Shazam and
Jason Momoa is going to be done as
Aquaman I think it's pretty clear that
James Gunn and Peter saffron are doing a
complete reboot especially after what
Dave Batista said but if you're about to
promote a movie you're not really going
to say that you're not going to promote
it by saying hey go see this because
it's my last film as Shazam and my last
film is Aquaman that's just not what
you're going to say you're going to say
hey don't worry about it go watch the
movie it's gonna be a great movie so I
think that's what the actors are going
to do I think they're both done with
Aquaman and Shazam which is sad because
I think both did an excellent job
portraying their characters but I think
both movies will be good and like I said
Jason Momoa will most likely be Lobo in
the DC Universe moving forward now as
far as winter expect some reveal of the
DCU slate James Gunn did tell us that he
would be revealing the Slate or at least
a part of it this month for those of you
who may not know James Gunn told us that
he's got basically eight to ten years of
the new DC Universe planned out however
he did say that he's not going to reveal
all of it in his announcement that he is
going to make this month now we only
have two days left in this month really
only one today is January 30th and
tomorrow is the 31st and rumor has it
that tomorrow he will reveal the first
part of the DCU slate which I believe he
is going to call chapters there's an
image going around of him responding to
an Instagram comment of him saying the
word chapters much like Marvel Studios
use as phases James could simply be
referring to phases as chapters to make
it different from the MCU however I
don't think anyone can confirm if he
actually made this comment or if it's
photoshopped so take that with a grain
of salt but regardless James Gunn has
said and you can find this on his
Twitter that he would reveal part of the
DC slate this month so today or tomorrow
and James Gunn is a person who is very
active on Twitter and he's also a man of
his word now of course things happen and
there could have been some things that
have popped up that could have gotten in
the way of him revealing to DC slate
this month however like I said since
he's so active on Twitter he would come
out and announce this he would tell us
he would probably come out and say sorry
it's not going to be this month but
it'll be soon and since we're a day away
and he hasn't said that yet I'm gonna go
ahead and guess that we probably are
still on track and if the DC slate
reveal really is tomorrow I gotta say
that's pretty funny him making us wait
the entire month and revealing it on the
very last day I can see him coming out
laughing and smiling saying hey I told
you it would be this month didn't I I
think that would be absolutely hilarious
and hey only one day left until we find
out that we're not gonna get it this
month or we will get it and we'll know
the first couple of years probably of
the new DCU so of course if something
happens we'll do a video on it so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest DC videos and let
us know in the comments down below what
you're looking forward to the most and
which characters you would like to see
arrive first in the new DCU don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf